keep your grip step so that your hand is
all the way on move there move your body
so they keep your
grip let go and now push him away keep
your feet on the ground try it again
yes let go bend your
knees okay let me show you again
okay so when he goes I step so I keep my
palm on his hand I put my foot where I
can do that he goes and here's where I
can do it then I'm going to let go and
all I'm going to do is shift my weight
forward now I lost it my foot didn't
move I didn't go where it needs to go I
need to be over here here's where I need
to be and if you're in the right place
come
push boom athletic boom
push don't lose your balance
here step in to keep your balance let go
push okay try it again okay follow your
hand be right underneath him bend your
knees so you're lower than him now let
go and now do it there you
go you can do the other side okay follow
your foot closer to him stay with your
hand whoops is peeling bend your knees
so that you're underneath him and
athletic there you
go bend your knees get underneath
[Music]
it that's
it another one this time I'm I'm
nogget there I come
here I'm going to let go and I'm going
to push
him boom let
go
boom so I'm in a good stance not a goofy
stance where I can't push
it let
go oh let go boom okay let's
try if you get knock down you do your
kimy otherwise just ride the
energy go it's all right to get pushed
get used to
it good
okay we trade
rolls put the hand underneath you step
to the
outside well bend your knees you won't
there bend your knees now let go and now
push him keep your knees bent with your
straight legs you won't have power try
it
again bend your knees bend your knees
fix your feet stop bend your knees get
your back straight okay now let go and
now push much better keep your knees
bent very good let's try the other
side put it underneath you and bend your
knees s it up straight with your back
put it underneath you good touch his
face with the other hand boom there you
go oops got to bend our knees try it
again same side
say yes Sensei yes Sensei put it
underneath
you good sit up straight bend your knees
more Let Go two hands push
them whoops keep your knees
bent watch my knees look at my
knees you see how bent they are and when
I push I don't want to straighten them I
keep them bent bent
stay bent stay low okay try it
again knees bent bent bent bent more
keep them down there push from
there don't come up try harder say yes
Sensei yes
Sensei lower straighten your back stay
low stay
low
better very
good other
side underneath you sit up straight bend
your knees a lot stay stay down when you
push two hands stay down oops you came
up do it
again bend your knees more stay down
there when you push just push with your
arms
better okay I go down and he's going to
try to push me like before so he's going
to
push oh he
pushes he right when right when I feel
him start to lean into me I'm going to
move out of the
way throw him past me
so here's where I start the game he
goes at the beginning he's going to push
slow just gradually you
see he goes I move out of the
way and I'm still in a good knee B
[Music]
and I push him okay try he's going to go
slow and when he goes slow move out of
the way and push him where he's
going yep push bend your knees when you
push try it
again put it under you bend your knees
bend your knees bend your knees stop
bend your
knees let go straighten your
back he's going to start to push move
out of the way keep your knees bent and
push him bend your
knees try it
again underneath
you there you
go when he starts to push you move keep
your knees bent and you push
him good very
good he's going to go a little faster
this time
underneath you bend your knees
straighten your back bend your knees
more bend your knees there you
go push them bend your knees try it
again come on shove
them bend your knees stay down there
move out of the way shove them hard good
do it again faster here we go
smoother good
faster yep bend your knees go
go see when your legs are straight you
can't do it try it
again
faster there you go
[Music]
good good
good faster now faster and
harder good faster and
harder hey you didn't get your arm on
the other side get your arm to the
outside say yes and say yes
and good